[Musique]
je vous propose de faire un petit détour
par le csa pour observer celles et ceux
qui nous observent l'équipe chargée de
vérifier l'exactitude des temps
d'antenne à la télévision
reportage patricia charnolé fils ja cela
aucune intervention politique n'échappe
à la vigilance du conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel
pendant cette campagne électorale toutes
les chaînes de radio et de télévision
sont écoutés chronométrés quinze
personnes visionnent tout ce qui est
politique
reportage ou débat chaque séquence est
décortiqué les médias audiovisuels sont
soumis à la même règle
le principe d'équité entre la majorité
et l'opposition s'est donné à tous ceux
qui ont une représentation forte un
temps d'antenne et de parole normale et
aux autres un temps d'antenne et de
parole susceptibles d'éclairer
les citoyens téléspectateurs jusqu'à
présent les équilibres sont globalement
respecté les membres du csa n'ont donc
pas eu à jouer les gendarmes les chaînes
d'ailleurs anticipe les critiques en
contrôlant elles mêmes leurs antennes
ainsi à france 2 un relevé quotidien des
prises de parole politique est établi ce
système d'après tous les spécialistes
n'est sans doute pas parfait mais il
existe depuis 20 ans et seule une loi
pourrait le modifier
[Musique]